Welcome to unit 4!
Unit 4 will be a little different from previous units.
We are gonna start in right away by finishing the code for the search engine.
What we have built so far is a web crawler.
It can follow content on web pages, following links to find other pages,
but it doesn't actually respond to queries.
What we are going to build in this unit is a search engine,
where we can pass in a keyword and get a list of the pages that contain that keyword.
We are also going to learn how the Internet works and the World Wide Web.
The main new computer science idea in this unit is the idea of how to use and build complex data structures.
In order to respond to queries quickly, we want to be able to have a data structure
where we can look up a keyword and quickly find the pages that match that keyword,
without needing to scan all pages every time.
To do this we are going to build a structure called an inverted index, or often just - an index,
that allows us to have a mapping between keywords and pages that contain these keywords.
Our index is really the same idea as an index in a book.
I happen to have a book handy.
That is one of my favorites. I might be a little biased, since I wrote it.
But let's take a look and see if there is anything in the book that would help us understand index searching.
We could try to read the whole book, see if there is anything about index search in here,
or we could go to the index, and if we are lucky, the index will have what we have, it's got "index search".
As each keyword in the index it has the page number, so we would go to the page number where that is found,
and instead of needing to read the whole book to try to find what we are looking for,
if we can find the right page, we will find the section on index search right away.
So that's the goal of an index.
For our search engine what we want is an index that provides a mapping
from keywords to list of webpages where that keyword appears.